Evans in North Carolina Evan welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show how can Anthony and
me help hey Anthony Dave how are you
guys
right good yes my question revolves on
take-home pay
I heard you use it in general rules of
thumb and I've heard it elsewhere in
financial advice and I was just
wondering what constitutes take-home pay
it should just be after taxes after
taxes and not after insurance and
retirement contributions right because
you would do those things if you didn't
have those available through your
company you would just do those out of
your checking account at home like for
instance you were self-employed you
would pay your taxes and that would be
your take-home pay and then you know you
can you make your decision from there on
the other stuff I mean you do your
retirement to the side you do your
insurance to the side I mean there's a
lot of stuff you can have taken out of
your pay yeah I mean sometimes you'd
have the car payment paid at the credit
union through work out of your pay but
that's not the definition of take-home
pay okay
so from a budgeting perspective should I
retro actively add retirement
contributions because technically those
you know numbers aren't reaching my
checking account they're going straight
into an investing account unless you're
trying to do something weird with your
budget I wouldn't fool with that but the
only reason I used take-home pay the
only thing we really use it for around
here is we're trying to see a how much
available cash do you have in your hand
to pay your bills with that you got at
home and in that case you're doing that
after retirement and after because you
know what are you getting home with to
pay bills with and then the other place
we use it is is 25% to take home pay on
a 15-year fixed rate is a gauge for your
mortgage but you know like if you're
running there every dollar budget
Anthony you you don't take you know you
you don't add retirement back in and
then take it back out of every dollar
budget no sir no sir my take-home pay
for me it's like what you're saying day
what is deposited in my
count that's my cash that's what I
budget off of and so Evan so what you're
asking Dave is should I add that in my
budget no just whatever your cheque is
that should take on BAE you know when
you get really worried for your
budgeting / yes for budgeting purposes
that Saul I would treat it because but
the technical definition of take-home
pay is after taxes yes okay but let's
say let's say you got in 401k coming out
okay so you add it back in and then you
take it back out in your budget that's
just creating extra work yeah if you're
doing it for budgeting purposes is that
logical yeah yeah okay you're just
adding a step to your budget that's not
necessary
instead you go this how much cash I got
every one of those dollars needs a name
and that's how you do yours right yes
sir okay and that's how you teach folks
right yes sir making sure we got the
same thing going your head gets screwed
up with the budgeting app because my
brain still works on a yellow pad yeah I
mean I let every dollar is much better
than a yellow pad but because it's kind
of designed off of the way a yellow pad
works I put the number at the top that I
got to work with and I give every dollar
an assignment yes sir and that's what
that's why it's called every dollar yes
it's just a new generation thing davier
you get the Oder here on a radio